in the aftermath of the dollar flu
several hostile groups rose up to take
advantage of the mayhem and reduction in
law enforcement
so what would happen if we took one of
the largest gangs from new york city
and one from washington dc and put them
up against each other to fight for
[Music]
[Music]
dominance
it wasn't long after the initial
outbreak that many public services
started to fail in new york city
and one of these areas being affected
was the prison complex on riker's island
so unsurprisingly the inmates took
advantage of the blackout
and the dwindling guard presence and
managed to overpower the captives
and break free breaking off the island
and into a number of neighbouring
districts
a large group of convicts found
themselves in manhattan one of the
hardest hit areas in the city
where law enforcement was almost
non-existent
one of the prison's most intimidating
inmates larry barrett
was highly successful in organizing this
group into a gang she called the rikers
and eagerly this hardened group of
criminals relished in the anarchy
where they could do whatever they wanted
which included enacting revenge on the
people that put them behind bars
their ranks grew quickly and they began
to have a large number of followers
as many of the riker island inmates
belonged to local new york gangs
this growth led to occasional inviting
but barrett's iron-fisted leadership
helped keep the gang in line she was
known for her ability to plan organise
and lead as well as being treacherous
murderous
and unforgiving as the jtf withdrew from
the streets of manhattan
the rikers flooded in behind them
quickly seizing control of entire
neighborhoods
the rikers have one goal eliminate
anyone in a uniform
[Music]
with the other hostile factions we're
born from betrayal revenge
or losing faith in the government's
ability to get things done the hyenas
are simply looking to cash in
on the current state of the city
resources were stretched thin
across the city as the jtf attempted to
control the outbreak
this meant that there were less people
around to stop the unlawful activity
committed by gangs and other criminal
groups
with all of the free reign to do what
they pleased the severity of their
crimes
quickly escalated and the gang
territories further increased in size
but because of this it led to gangs
fighting between each other
to see who could carve out most of the
city for themselves
however there was now another group that
was to take to the streets of washington
dc
the true sons had broken off from the
jtf and formed their own group
the jtf and the government weren't
getting results so in order to bring
structure back to the city
it was up to them anyone who stood in
their way would be dealt with
jtf civilians and especially anyone who
is creating more chaos during the crisis
the gangs of dc quickly found themselves
outgunned and rapidly losing territory
the true sons were militarized
disciplined and had far superior weapons
and equipment
and unlike the law enforcement from
before the outbreak they went there to
arrest them
they were there to exterminate them
eventually a gang leader who emperor the
alias coyote
managed to bring six of the largest
gangs together and proposed that they
stopped fighting amongst themselves
and unify they all faced a common enemy
who was too strong to take on alone
but together they would stand a chance
this group would soon be known as
the hyenas
both factions have a number of loose
roles within their ranks
the bulk of rikers are made up of the
assault class and are skilled in the use
of their weapons
but they also have explosive experts and
tanks who are equipped with nail guns
and riot shields
the personnel placed in the russia role
have been afforded this because they
have proven time and time again to be
too erratic
and have a lack of danger awareness the
heavy weapons rikers are ex-military
their training armor and heavy machine
guns offer powerful support to the rest
of the army
the hyenas typically prefer close range
combat but they do have other classes
and support
for example their controllers are
considered to be the intellectuals
within the group
they have knowledge and mechanics and
operate remote control cars
rigged with explosives hyena engineers
use their sniper turrets to suppress
enemies
while the bulk of the russia classes get
into place
their rushes are loose cannons and can
often be seen using drugs to boost their
adrenaline
before beelining straight towards the
enemy
other than a handful of rikers who are
ex-military the bulk of the members in
each of these groups
have minimal to no recognised military
or firearms training
but due to the nature of where they came
from and what they were doing before the
outbreak
they're reasonably familiar with weapons
and how to use them
when coming up against a more
disciplined foe they more than make up
for this with brutality
and sheer numbers
both factions can be seen wielding
various types of assault rifles
lmgs marksman rifles smgs and shotguns
most of their weapons have been acquired
from prison guards jtf
peacekeepers and other hostile factions
hyenas tend to prefer the use of close
range weapons like submachine guns
pistols and shotguns as well as riot
shields
shock batons and a variety of grenades
rikers recognise the need for variety in
their arsenal placing slightly more
importance on light machine guns
sniper turrets and remote control cars
with explosives strapped to them
the hyenas typically prefer to quickly
rush their enemies down and fight in
close quarters
their tactics involve forcing their
opponents out of cover and managing to
disorientate them before they can gather
their bearings
their combat is unorthodox they
disregard cover shoot without aiming
and are often taking drugs before
manically charging ahead
shield russia and assault archetypes are
found closest to enemies
pushing ahead while medic engineer and
tank archetypes
are closely behind setting up their
equipment reviving any dead hyenas
and laying down suppressive fire
controller
thrower and sniper archetypes are found
at vantage points in the battlefield
using the gear to support their allies
and disorientate enemies
the assault class makes up the backbone
of the riker forces
they will lay down fire while constantly
attempting to catch their enemies off
guard through flanking techniques
rushers will push forward with shotguns
and smgs while throwers sit back
attempting to flush enemies out of cover
using grenades
rikers snipers deal a decent amount of
damage and should be focused down when
present
their tanks will move slowly through the
battlefield able to take considerable
damage
while their allies flank and get into
position
the heavy weapon class lays down the
bulk of their firepower assembling
shielded mini-gun platforms
where they're able to provide a decent
amount of suppressive fire
both of these groups have resulted as
opportunists from the aftermath of the
outbreak
scavengers thieves and murderers who
pray on the week for resources
and will kill for no other reason than
entertainment
however in this fight i'm gonna have to
give it to the rikers
the hyenas show a complete lack of
discipline often found roaming around in
groups
and charging recklessly into battle
rather than holding their ground
and this lack of tactics is really only
made up for by the sheer numbers they
have
where the rikers although not trained in
any way they position themselves in a
slightly more
organized manner under the leadership of
their former leader
barrett they resembled a force that was
somewhat disciplined
and had tactics to back it up however
with their now dead
it isn't quite so obvious but still
swings in their favor
the main asset that the hyenas hold is
their numbers
as a loose guide we could look at the
number of gangs that are present in
washington dc today
the gangs of dc are not the highly
organized gangs of los angeles and
chicago
with their clearly identifiable
hierarchies initiation rights
and colours instead if we look at crews
of people
10 or more who commit crimes together
there are more than 70 known groups
some with over 100 members but there is
believed to be at least 200 more
operating in the city
so if we wanted to come up with a
conservative number it would be safe to
say that there are at least 5 000 gang
members in dc
who would have potentially fallen under
the hyena banner and as the law states
their numbers were considerably
bolstered by the collapse of society and
the breakdown of law enforcement
where even people who may not have been
this way inclined felt they had no
choice but to join
in order to survive so maybe we're
looking at 8 000
10 000 even remember these numbers could
be considerably higher
then we have the rikers at any time
rikers island usually houses around 10
000 inmates
not all of these inmates are hardened
violent criminals
a decent chunk of them are there
awaiting sentencing or a short term
then we need to remember that a lot of
them were getting sick from the virus
let's say that 5 000 inmates were able
to escape on the day that they overthrew
the guards
they didn't all head straight to
manhattan they also fled over to the
other side of the river into queens
but let's be generous and say that 3 000
of the inmates landed on manhattan and
came together as one
under the leadership of larry barrett
so 3 000 slightly organized inmates
using a larger range of weapons
and with more experience using them
versus 10 000 completely inexperienced
street thugs
who rely purely on numbers to overcome
their enemies
tough call but i know which side i'd put
my money on and i'll tell you why
the largest issue that the hyenas have
is the way that they're structured at
the very top
they are led by a council each of the
six members are the leader of their own
clan within the hyenas
this leader represents them in the
council acting as the speaker and voice
of his or her clan
represented in the council this has led
to considerable infighting between the
clans
where they are constantly scheming for
ways to gain more resources and
prominent positions within the overall
gang
there is a lot of bickering and
backstabbing they all hate each other
and would gladly stab each other in the
back when the opportunity presents
itself
this has led to leadership that often
changes hands
on top of this the majority of the hyena
members consists of youths
and late teens yes there was some
infighting in the rikers
that was only being contained by barrett
but later on
after a death when they were under the
leadership of rogue shd agent
james dragoff we see that over time
their loyalty towards each other has
only grown
as they now resemble more of a crime
family
in summary the hyena's large numbers
don't make up for their lack of
discipline
organization training and experience
i'm not even going to get into the
manufacturing use of drugs and the fact
that some of their archetypes are so
ill-equipped to handle the explosives
and weapons they're using
that they're more likely to do damage to
their allies in themselves
than others
i've had some really cool ideas come out
of the comments for other videos where i
put groups or characters up against each
other
both from within tom clancy and across
other games too
i'm obviously relatively knowledgeable
about tom clancy games but the others
may take me a little more time to
research which is good keep the
suggestions coming
anyway thank you very much for watching
and i'll catch in the next one cheers
[Applause]
[Music]
you